okay welcome up Nicola and you tell us
about streaming a little matchings in
lower diversity graphs
all right so hello everyone today I'm
going to talk about graph streams and
approximating the size of maximum
matching in lower-body graphs this is
joint work with Andrew McGregor
so I'm going to start with talking about
the streaming model and why we might
want to use it and I'm going to use
social networks as an example throughout
my talk so let's say we want to
represent a social network as a graph
and then solve some problem on that
graph so then users of the networks
would correspond to vertices and there
are friendships to the edges and if you
go to someone's page and look at their
friends list then what you're getting is
basically a list of edges which are
incident to a particular vertex in the
graph um however social networks are not
static because people can friend and
unfriend each other which would
correspond to the edges of the
underlying graph being added and deleted
and note that now those updates are no
longer grouped by user or verdicts they
just come in some arbitrary order and we
can also consider it a slightly simpler
model where we can only add friends but
not delete them because if you unfriend
someone they will be very offended and
in this model the updates still come in
an arbitrary order but we're only adding
edges to the graph so let's see how that
is related to the streaming model in
streaming we're assuming that we know
the vertices of the graph in advanced
though for some algorithms we don't need
the assumption we start with an empty
graph with no edges and then observe a
sequence of edge updates and we can only
look at the sequence once so we're
saying that we're taking one task over
the stream so these are the three
streaming models that I'll be talking
about today the most general one is
dynamic streaming where updates come in
arbitrary order and we can both in
certain delete edges in the graph now in
insert only model the weather is still
arbitrary however we can only insert
edges but not delete them and then
finally an adjacency list streams were
only inserting edges and now edges
incident to the same vertex arrived
together in the stream and actually
we're going to see every edge twice once
for each of its endpoints so we want to
compute some function of this graph that
is defined by our stream the problems
considered are such as maximum matching
determining whether the graph is
connected counting the number of
triangles and so on and our main
objective is to minimize the amount of
space that our algorithm is using
because we're assuming that the graph
that we're dealing with is real a large
and in particular we cannot store all of
it first update time is also generally
encouraged but on the other hand we're
assuming that were only extracting the
solution once at the very end of the
stream so the post processing time can
be quite large so why do you want to use
the small first as I mentioned are we're
assuming that the graph is really large
so it doesn't are fit into main memory
and then if we're reading it from some
sort of external memory device then this
sequential reading can be faster than
random access the graph can also be
distributed across our multiple machines
in which case our edge by edge approach
is just an extreme case of a batch by
batch and finally the graph can be
changing over time and streaming allows
us to store and update just the summary
of the data as opposed to the entire
dataset
so in general we want our model to be
quite restricted but on the other hand
we want to solve general graph theoretic
problems and this way we come up with
techniques that extend to other models
and also can be used in a variety of
applications
so the main thing that can be done in
graph streams is sampling we can sample
edges uniformly non uniformly we can
also sample vertices and then collect
incident edges on them other things that
can be done easily are computed the
degrees of vertices or some other
quantities that depend on the degrees
and finally some algorithms also take
the ordering of the stream into account
so let me just quickly go over of how we
can sample edges so assume we just want
to sample one random edge from uniformly
at random from the set of all edges in
the graph if the stream only has
insertions then it can be easily done by
reservoir sampling where we're keeping
the first edge in the stream and then
for each eyes edge we replace the edge
that were currently storing with this e
sub I with probability 1 over I and then
at the end of the stream who have a
random edge if the stream has both
insertions and deletions sampling random
edge is not quite as intuitive we have
to use what is called a zero sampling
where such a sampler returns random edge
fails with probability Delta and its
uses spaced roughly log squared n times
log Delta to the negative 1 so it can
make this failure probability as small
as we want at the expense of a slight
increase in space of the algorithm and
I'm not going to go into the detail of
how a zero something works we're just
going to use it as a black box and
finally if we need to sample a set of
vertices we can use a hash function to
do that so we can do it on the fly as
opposed to pre sampling in the beginning
of the algorithm and storing all that
information the extra sample waves or
something also it might on it might not
even return an edge there's a valid edge
of the graph
okay so the particular graph problem
that I'll be talking about today is
maximum matching and let's go back to
our example of a social network imagine
that your computer science department is
organizing an event and each grad
student is allowed to bring a plus-one
but since their grad students they don't
have friends outside of the department
and what the one should do is basically
to pair up among each other and this is
an example of such pairing so the
students were paired up are happy and
the rest of them are very sad and lonely
so we want to minimize the number of
unhappy students by maximizing the
number of pairs and then the list of
terrorists in zone is then called the
matching in this graph so defined more
formally a matching is a set of edges of
the graph that don't share any end
points and we want to find out such a
set of maximum size so in this graph for
example the two green edges form a
matching and it is a maximum matching in
this graph
so if our stream are only has insertions
then we can just run the greedy
algorithm to obtain a maximal matching
which immediately gives us a to
approximation of maximum matching
however imagine can be as large as n
over 2 so that algorithm uses linear
space in the number of vertices so
maximal means that we cannot add more
edges to the matching and maximum means
of maximal size and those can be a
factor of two away from each other so if
we want to do better than used on linear
space then what we can do is instead of
finding the edges of the matching itself
we can just try to approximate the size
of it and in some cases that gives us
sub linear space in particular I will be
concentrated concentrating on the class
of graphs of obesity alpha where our
Barossa t is the minimum number of
forests into which we can't
to shunt the edges of the graph so this
graph for example has our bracele -
because the edges can be partitioned
into the blue forest and the red forest
our birthday is closely related to the
density of the graph in particular if
the obesity is low then there are no
dense sub-graphs in the graph and vice
versa
in fact every sub graph on R vertices
has at most of our edges if their
veracity of the graph is alpha and
bounded our birthday is actually a
reasonable assumption for many real life
networks for example in social networks
there might be some dense sub-graphs
corresponding to front groups and
communities however the size of those
groups is relatively small compared to
the size of the entire network so we can
say that there is an upper bound on the
arbor III of the graph and also another
well-known well-known class of graphs of
flow are bursa t are planar graphs which
have our bursa t at most 3 and let me
just note that in dynamic streams where
we we can both insert and delete edges
the intermediate graphs in the middle of
the stream can have higher bursaries we
just scared that at the very end the
last graph has Arbor III bounded by
alpha so these are all the results on
approximating the size of Naxal matching
in our bursa T alpha graphs the ones in
blue are the ones I will be talking
about today so be presenting an alpha
plus 2 approximation using space of n to
the 4/5 which is sub linear in the
number of vertices if alpha is small
enough in 2017 core mode at all
presented another algorithm that returns
an approximation which is linear in
alpha which use a slightly smaller space
alpha to the 10 thirds times and to the
2/3 however their algorithm has one
restriction that the number of deletions
is limited to offer end
and there's also a lower bound that says
that if we want an approximation factor
linear in alpha then in dynamic streams
we basically need to know we need to use
root n space so our dynamic algorithm
can also be slightly modified to be used
in insert only model with the reduction
in space so it gives a space of n to 2/3
however I'm also going to present a
better algorithm for the insert only
model which has the same approximation
factor but uses much smaller space which
is merely logarithmic and then finally
for adjacent to extremes I'll present an
alpha plus 2 approximation which uses
constant space and here when I talk
about space it's specified in words so
one edge or a counter can be stored in
one word of space so I'll be talking
about three algorithms one for each
trimming model but all three results
have the following two parts first there
is a structural result where we define
this quantity Sigma that is an alpha
plus 2 approximation of the size of max
you imagine in the graph and then there
is an algorithm which is enough 1 plus
epsilon approximation of this quantity
Sigma in the corresponding streaming
model and for adjacency with streams we
can actually compute it exactly so I
will be defining these three quantities
Sigma dynamic Sigma insert and Sigma
Jason C and then show how to compute 1
plus Epsilon approximations of the first
two and how to compute the last one
exactly so let me start with the
structural results first let me let me
make a few definitions we define a set
of heavy vertices which have degrees at
least alpha plus 2 and heavy edges which
have two heavy endpoints so these are
the ones in blue here at the top and
similarly we have white vertices of
degree smaller than alpha plus 2 and
light edges which have to light
endpoints so those are the ones in red
and so from that we can immediately
define Sigma adjacency which is just the
number of light edges plus the number of
heavy vertices times alpha plus 1 and
minus number of hedges so to define a
sigma dynamic we need to assign those
weights to each edge in the graph where
the weight of the edge UV is the minimum
of 1 over degree u 1 / degree V and 1
over alpha + 1 so let's say this graph
has adversity alpha equal to 2 these are
the degrees of all the vertices and so
these are are the weights that we assign
to all the edges
note that for example this edge has two
endpoints
of degree two but since their versity of
the graph is also two this last term is
the minimum one which gives us the 1/3
and then sigma dynamic is just the sum
of all those weights for all the edges
multiplied by alpha plus 1 so sigma
dynamic and sigma adjacency are closely
related so I'm going to present them as
one structural result first note that
the size of the matching in the graph is
at post the number of light edges plus
the number of heavy vertices because
every edge of the matching is either
light or it's incident share heavy
vertex then if we just expand this term
and apply the property of perversity
alpha graphs which tells us that number
of heavy edges is at most alpha times
the number of highly vertices then we
get Sigma Jason see in lemma one I'll
show that this is at most sigma dynamic
and ulema to that it's at most alpha
plus 2 times the size of the matching in
the graph so that immediately gives us
that both Sigma Jason C and Sigma
dynamic are alpha plus 2 approximations
of the matching
so I won't have time to give you full
proofs of dilemmas so just you will a
general idea
so for lemma one we want to split the
sum into three depending on what kind of
edge we're dealing with whether it's
light heavy or neither and then for each
of those three cases we can bound X of e
separately and then do some algebra to
relate that to the number of light and
heavy edges and heavy vertices in lemma
qu we first note that our assignment of
weights satisfies the conditions of
being a fractional matching and the
maximum weight there is at most one over
alpha plus one and then we can use
Edmonds theorem to relate the size of
the attraction or matching to the size
of maximum integral matching in the
graph so that would give us a lemma two
and finally let me talk about a sigma
insert first we define the set e sub
alpha which is the set of edges UV such
that the number of edges incident to
either you or V that appear in the rest
of the stream are both at most alpha and
let me give you an example let's say we
care about this edge E and this is its
neighborhood in the graph the numbers
correspond to the ordering of the stream
and let's say that the ARB erisa T of
the entire graph is 3 then these four
green edges are the ones that appear
alpha e in the stream and they're only
two of them for each endpoint which is
smaller than alpha and so the edge is in
the set e sub alpha however if we just
reorder the stream and move it closer to
the beginning of it now these six edges
are the one that appear after in the
stream and now four of them are incident
to this one endpoint which is greater
than alpha and so E is not in the set is
about fun so as you can see the set
depends on the stream ordering however
we can show that regardless of the
ordering the size of that set is always
enough
to approximation of the size of the
matching however we need to do a little
more work to define Sigma insert so
let's say that G sub T is the graph
consisting of the first t edges in the
stream and here we're dealing with an
insert only stream so G sub T is always
a sub graph of G and we'll let your
fatty be the set is above defined on the
sub graph applying dilemma we know that
the size of the set is a an alpha plus 2
approximation of the matching in the sub
graph G sub T and finally we define our
Sigma insert as the maximum over all
time steps T of the size of those sets
and note that even though we only have
insertions the size of those sets can go
up and down throughout the stream so
let's say that it is maximized at some
time capital T but then on the other
hand the size of the matching is a
monotonic non-decreasing function of T
and so we know that Sigma insert is on
the one hand greater than or equal to
the size of the matching and on the
other hand it is at most alpha plus
2,000 times the matching in the sub
graph G capital T which is at worst of a
plus 2 of the matching in the entire
graph so Sigma insert is still enough
applause to approximation of the
matching G and again I'll just give you
a general idea of the proof of lemma
three for the upper bound we define
those way it's y sub e where it's 1 over
alpha plus 1 if the edge is in the set
is above and 0 otherwise so as before we
can show that this is a fractional
matching with maximum weight 1 over
alpha plus 1 on the one hand the size of
that matching is exactly the size of the
set e Sababa r divided by alpha plus 1
and on the other hand we can use Edmonds
theorem chi related to the size of
maximum integral matching in the graph
so that would give us this upper bound
for the lower bound we just want to
carefully count light edges and adjust
their incidence you have vertices that
belong to the set Isabeau feh and then
from that we can show that the size of
the set is greater than or equal to the
number of light edges plus the number of
heavy vertices and as I mentioned before
this is at least the size of the
matching because each matching edge is
either light where it's incident you
have a vertex so now I'm going to switch
to the part of my talk about algorithms
and let's start with the most general
model the dynamic streams here once you
do the following two things in parallel
if the matching is small as in smaller
than and over 2/5 then we want to use a
completely unrelated algorithm for
matchings of bounded size where the
space used by the algorithm is quadratic
on this bound on the size of the
matching so it uses n to the 4/5 space
now if the matching is large we want to
estimate our Sigma dynamic and we will
be doing that by computing our weights X
appear for a particular set of edges
that I'll define in the next slide and
note that our approximation of Sigma
dynamic is only going to be accurate if
the size of the matching and thus the
size of Sigma dynamic itself in the
graph are large which is why we had to
split our algorithm into two in the
first place
and also note that in insert only
streams we can use the greedy algorithm
for approximating small matchings over
here and that uses linear space in the
size of the matching as opposed to
quadratic so that reduces the total
space to offer n to the 2/3 so now let's
see how to estimate Sigma dynamic first
of all we'll be sampling a set of 30 60
where each vertex is included in T with
probability roughly 1 over N to the 1/5
so the size of that set will be roughly
n to the 4/5 and for those vertices will
be computing the degrees and another
thing we need is a set of edges a sub T
which are the edges with both endpoints
in T and so since we know that at the
end of the stream the diversity of the
graph will be bounded by alpha the size
of that set will be at most of n to the
4/5 however in the middle of the stream
diversity can be higher so the size of
that set can be larger and if we don't
want our Chi use too much space we can't
just collect all the edges in a sub T
throughout the stream and what would you
instead is we use sampling and in
particular with sample the minimum of
the size of the set and of n to the 4/5
edges in a sub T and so this allows us
to limit the number of space we're using
but at the same time at the end of the
stream we will collect all the edges in
this set and so for our estimation of
Sigma dynamic we will just use our
weights X appear on those edges in the
set e sub T and we can compute those
weights because we know the degrees of
vertices in C and so not going to prove
that no question
well so we're assuming that would you
know alpha or at least some upper bound
on alpha and so I'm not really sure what
happens if you don't
so I would say that if our alpha is too
low that we will not be sampling enough
edges and so our estimate will be off so
we will not be getting the correct
approximation factor are you able to
detect that alpha itself after the facts
I'm not sure lakh times to test every
alpha yeah but then are your space will
be too large so your space depends on
Alpha all right
yes all right so we use this sum as our
estimate and I'm not going to show that
it is accurate it's just standard
applications of sharing often Union
bounds so I'm going to switch to insert
only streams and here the idea of the
algorithm is that we want to keep a
sample of edges in the set a alpha t at
each time step T such that on the one
hand we can get an accurate
approximation of the size of that set
and on the other hand we can use a small
amount of space so this is the algorithm
that we will be using we set our
sampling probability P to be one in the
beginning of the stream and then as
we're processing the edges we sample
each of them with probability P if the
edges sampled will store the edge and
will also store counters for the degrees
of its endpoints in the rest of the
stream if at some point we detect that
the edge is not in some Ceti alpha T so
one of the counters exceeded alpha we
just throw out that edge and also if at
any point in the algorithm the number of
edges we're storing exceeds for the
epsilon to negative two Logan then we
have the sampling probability and we
delete every edge we're currently
storing with probability 1/2 so we're
basically emulating sampling with lower
probability and then at the end of the
stream we want to return the maximum
overall time steps T of the number of
samples we were keeping at that time T
divided by the sampling probability at
the same time so now let's see why this
works let's define K to be such that our
Sigma insert is sandwiched between this
quantity times 2 to the K minus 1 and
the same quantity times 2 to the K and
we can show that with high probability
if our sampling probability is high
enough as in it is at least 1 over 2
decay then one can compute accurate
approximation of the sizes of our sets
alpha T for all T and here accuracy is
in terms of our Sigma insert so for the
largest such set we get 1 plus epsilon
approximation of Sigma insert for
smaller sets we might not get a 1 for
self approximation but we don't care
about those because we just care about
the maximum one and so this just follows
again from journals and Union bounds and
the second thing we want to show is that
we do not switch to probability which is
too low as in smaller than 1 over 2 to
the K and that happens if you actually
get down to sampling probability 1 over
2 to the K then the number of samples
you're storing does not exceed 1 plus
epsilon times Sigma insert divided by 2
to the K which is strictly less than for
the epsilon 2 negative 2 log n which was
our cutoff to switching to lower
probability so that does not happen and
the last thing I'll be talking about or
adjacent to lift streams and here we
actually just need the degrees of the
vertices in the graph so we treat our
adjacent to a stream as the degree
sequence so from that the number of
heavy vertices can be easily computed by
just keeping a counter as for these two
terms we note that if we take the sum
over all hairy vertices of the degrees
of those vertices then we count each
blue heavy edge twice and each grey edge
once and if we subtract that from all
the edges in the graph we get exactly
the light edges minus the heavy edges
which is what we wanted to compute and
this two quantities can also be easily
computed from the degree sequence by
just storing a couple of counters so
this gives us a constant space algorithm
all right so in conclusion I just want
to give a quick summary so I talked
about a few quantities that give a good
approximation of the size of Max imagine
if we know that the obesity of our graph
is bounded by alpha and I also showed
how those quantities can be efficiently
computed in various streaming models so
there are a few questions that are still
open first of all so far it looks like
our methods only give us alpha plus 2
approximation so question is whether we
can do better than that and second for
dynamic streams there's still a gap
between upper and lower bounds on the
space that the algorithm uses so closing
that gap would be another open question
and this is all for me thank you for
your attention thank you for new
questions there's actually a few minutes
5 minutes of these questions
so what if you have make a setting where
you can really look at some parts of the
graph ice pockets and they'd have to
stitch the magics across one of those so
something like a realization of I think
I could also live in my stream and
something that gives me a chunk of data
well I guess in this case you can kind
of view the stream as like the first
part of the stream is you looking at the
first chunk the second part of the
stream is you looking at the second
chunk so every time you're looking at
the new chunk you will have some summary
of the ones you looked at before so if
you end up processing the entire graph
in your chunks then yes you can see
there's a stream
yes
yes so we haven't actually looked at
random other streams for this model so
I'm not sure if that would give you any
advantage but yes for some problems
assuming that your ordering is random
doesn't prove you algorithm
yes